contrairement à ce qu'affirme le
gouvernement brésilien les incendies
sont loin d'être sous contrôle en
amazonie plus de mille nouveaux
incendies ont été constatés dont plus de
50% en amazonie selon l'institut
national de recherches spatiales
quels sont donc les enjeux économiques
en lien avec ses feux dans la plus
grande forêt tropicale du québec donne
furukawa marquez et professeur adjoint
au département de sociologie de
l'université laval à québec
messieurs marquez bonsoir bonsoir
pourquoi ces feux de forêt ont lieu en
ce moment
d'abord bon alors la raison pour
laquelle on parle beaucoup de ces feux
en ce moment c'est que vous venez de
citer
l' agence nationale de recherches
spatiales qui nous apprenait au début de
l'été que pour la même période l'année
passée
on constate cette année une augmentation
de 84 % des feux donc est-ce que c'est
anodin et bien non parce que si on
remonte à l'élection du président actuel
du brésil berceau narrow il nous disait
explicitement dès son élection que la
masoni pour lui représenté d'abord et
avant tout un potentiel économique
donc il nous disait clairement qu'il
allait ouvrir les portes de l'amazonie
au capital étranger aux capitaux
étrangers et nationaux pour qu'on puisse
exploiter les ressources que la forêt
présente qu'elle est quelles sont donc
les liens le lien que vous faites entre
les incendies et ball zone euro est bien
beau scénario a été élu avec une large
appui un appui massif d'un des trois
lobby principaux au congrès brésilien le
lobby de l'agrobusiness
les deux autres étant les évangéliques
et tout ce qui est relié à la à l'armée
à la police
et donc il avait une volonté claire de
plaire à son à cet appui électorale donc
il avait dit qu'il allait ouvrir
l'amazonie ce qui est important de
savoir c'est que on constate avec les
chiffres qu'une fois que des terres en
forêt sont brûlés sont dévastés par le
feu un certain temps plus tard 65 % de
ces terres deviennent des terres de
pâturages pour l'élevage bovin le brésil
étant un des principaux exportateurs de
viande au monde
qui est évidemment contrôlé par les
multinationales de l'agro business
au brésil on parle notamment de la
compagnie jbs qui est une la principale
compagnie exportatrice de viande au
monde donc un intérêt il ya un lien
clair entre l'agrobusiness ces
compagnies là et les politiques de bords
sont donc autrement dit il ya entre
guillemets la fois la forêt amazonienne
dévastée a un potentiel économique
elle a un potentiel économique claire et
d'autant plus dans le contexte actuel où
il ya une demande très accrue de viande
et de soya dans le monde donc une partie
de ces terres là devient aussi des des
terres pour la monoculture du soya je
veux présenter un tableau que vous nous
avez préparé des des données qui nous
montre clairement l'utilisation par les
paysans et par les grands groupes ce que
vous appelez l'agrobusiness les grands
groupes alimentaires le le crédit
agricole utilisée par les paysans à 14%
mais les grands groupes utilisent à 86%
de crise agricole
les terres sont utilisés en grande
partie ou en tout cas sont propriétés en
grande partie des grands groupes 76 pour
ça on à la production globale
majoritairement des grands groupes mais
la production d'aliments vient surtout
des paysans à 70% et la main d'oeuvre
aussi à 74% du côté des paysans
alors une fois que j'ai des crises aux
caisses que qu'est ce qu'on doit
comprendre de ces chiffres on doit
comprendre que comme vous venez de le
décrire les subventions gouvernementales
pour l'agriculture brésilienne vont
d'abord et avant tout à l'agrobusiness
donc la monoculture de soya la viande le
blé etc
les paysans reçoivent une très petite
partie de cette subvention là et les
terres c'est la même chose ils
détiennent une très petite partie de ces
terres là mais c'est eux qui emploient
le plus de main d'oeuvre et qui sont
responsables de la consommation de 70
pour ça des aliments que les brésiliens
consomme à tous les jours donc ce qu'on
constate c'est que l'agro business donc
l'industrie de l'agro business
elle produit d'abord et avant tout des
marchandises qui ne sont pas des
aliments ce n'est pas de la nourriture
que les gens vont manger
c'est d'abord et avant tout des
marchandises qui vont être
commercialisés comme le grain pour
l'élevage de bovins mais aussi l'agro
combustible que le brésil est un des
pionniers des pays pionniers d'avoir de
développement de l'agro combustible
notamment à travers l'éthanol et donc
est ce qu'on imagine qu'ils ont un
impact sur le système alimentaire
mondial
un impact de ces feux en amazonie
présentement oui en fait un point que
j'aimerais soulever c'est que j'ai vu
circuler un peu dans des explications
dans les médias que si on manger moins
de viande on aurait pas de fait en
amazonie pourquoi parce que gêné je
viens de le dire 65 % de ces terres là
qui sont dévastés par les feux
deviennent plus tard des terres de
pâturages pour l'élevage bovin donc son
consomment moins de viande on aurait
moins d'intérêt économique a provoqué
ces feux l'acfe là sont causés par des
causes humaines
on sait actuellement par exemple que la
chine consomme une grande partie de
cette viande là mais ce que j'aimerais
attirer l'attention c'est que c'est plus
complexe que seulement la consommation
de viande dans le monde pourquoi parce
que le système alimentaire mondial
aujourd'hui participe du système
économique mondial en général
le capitalisme est si on constate si on
regarde un peu ce qui s'est passé depuis
les années 80 90 il y a eu une
libéralisation très prononcé du commerce
mondial de l'alimentation et les
conséquences a été que les capitaux
étrangers sont arrivés dans les pays du
sud majoritairement et ont commencé à
déposséder les paysans qui était
responsable de la production d'aliments
pour en faire des tas de monoculture
donc ça ça fait que là il s'est produit
une concentration des joueurs de
l'industrie
on a eu vraiment quelques unes point de
multinationales qui domine un peu tout
le marché d'aliments de dimension
mondiale et à cela s'ajoute aussi une
demande accrue oui de viande donc c'est
un autre facteur qui rentre dans
l'explication et l'autre facteur c'est
la demande accrue également d'
agrocombustibles d'énergie mais qui se
traduit principalement par l'agro
combustible donc ces facteurs mis
ensemble on crée une pression mondiale
sur le système alimentaire pour
augmenter la production d'agro
combustible et
de viande notamment donc qui dit
augmentation de la production 10
opportunités de profits potentiels
évidemment est donc là on est dans la
recherche de plus amples de plus en plus
de terres pour pratiquer 7,7 agro
industrie voit la pression économique
très importante sur marquez merci pour
cette explication ce soir merci à vous
savez pouvoir au revoir